[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Gupta vpgm for infrastructure at Google
Cloud
the roles of Enterprise Architects and
developers are evolving
not only do you have to keep the lights
on you are expected to stay on top of
the ever-changing trends and
technologies that create business value
and you have to do all of this while
lowering costs and improving performance
so it infrastructure runs quickly and
smoothly
Your Role is critical to a successful
transformation with Google Cloud you can
innovate faster and more easily while
optimizing costs we know organizations
like yours still have a lot of
infrastructure to migrate and we are
committed to helping you migrate more
securely and efficiently Cloud TPU V4
delivers industry leading ml training
performance and scale with six terabytes
per second interconnect you can run
large-scale training workloads up to 80
faster and up to 50 percent cheaper
compared to Alternatives today we are
announcing a new industry Consortium the
open xla project that will unite an
ecosystem of leading machine learning
compiler Technologies and accelerate and
simplify machine learning Innovation
these open source AI contributions
enable you to take your AI idea and turn
it into reality easily and at low cost
VMware engine is a fully managed native
Google service that helps you lift and
shift your VMware applications to Google
Cloud faster and easier
we are the first external provider to
support vmware's Cloud Universal program
which makes it easier for you to migrate
to the cloud
and with built-in point-and-click
migration tools and our instant
provisioning feature you can get
workloads running in your private cloud
in less than one hour we are continuing
to scale VMware engine by increasing
support from 64 to 96 nodes per private
Cloud all with four lines of
availability in a single site and a
dedicated 100 gigabit per second Network
this provides high performance and
reliability for your most demanding
production workloads next I'm really
excited to announce C3 VMS
it is the first VM on the market to
feature the latest generation of Intel
Sapphire Rapids processors and is built
on new Intel Google co-designed
infrastructure processing units or ipus
all of this together means
differentiated performance security
isolation and flexibility
C3 is the first VM in our Fleet with 200
gigabits per second low latency
networking to support a variety of
workloads such as data processing web
serving and high throughput HPC
workloads moving on to another product
built to Leverage The ipu Google cloud
hyperdesk is the next generation of
block storage which will be available on
both compute engine and gke we are
decoupling block storage performance
from the VM allowing you to tune your
storage performance to your workload
needs our new flexible committed use
discounts or Flex Cuts can make it
easier to save and manage costs across
teams by giving you region and VM family
flexibility our new migration Center can
reduce complexity time and cost
by providing key capabilities in
migrating and modernizing to Virtual
machines containers or serverless
Computing dual run lets you replicate
your Mainframe workload in Google cloud
and run the two environments in parallel
this allows you to confirm successful
operations in Google Cloud
before your cutover which can massively
reduce risk
these three defining pillars for Google
Cloud infrastructure
transformative
optimized and easy
are the key tenets behind our
intentional engineering efforts thank
you
[Music]